to hello everybody happy Monday we are
back
for another week of bangers oh well
this one's a banger
as far as I'm aware the other four are
gonna be the usual kind of subpar but
this one I have a feeling is going to be
the good one of the week
thank you guys good to be here with you
all sponsored by gamer sup who we love
okay give it up
we love them
um
let's see well tomorrow where there's no
member stream I'll say that but the
reason is
is because I'm going to meet kavcav Ryan
Kavanaugh
and I will be packing with me a one
million dollar check for Habitat human
for Humanity I'm gonna have him co uh
sponsor it with me thank you
I'll also be bringing with me uh
some papers print out papers with him
side by side with Harvey Weinstein to
help differentiate the mediator and the
ju and the lawyers so that they can tell
we are not we are talking to Ryan
Cavanaugh and not Harvey Weinstein
capitalize
I'm also bringing a little device to my
pocket that plays just a bull sound
I click it and it goes oh you know what
I'll change my ringtone to and I'll have
you guys call me occasionally
I feel like you hear that Ryan
is that a bull
I didn't know wait hold on do you have a
live feed open of your living room
what's going on
oh sorry that's just my ringtone my bad
yeah you only hear about that in movies
like I I personally until I this video
I've never heard of that being a real
thing like a hands-free hold on um
cement chased his pants from just from
seeing hot feet
hands-free yeah it seemed like it was
hands-free [__] on the floor
hands-free baby down his leg down his
leg right onto the grocery store floor
which is so vile
so [__] vile imagine you're walking
down like the Frozen aisle
you slip in some mystery goo
you're like hmm
somebody spilled milk here
she was super duper duper hot yeah
but uh I
I went up to her I hugged her and I came
in my pants
dudes please bro don't ever say that
again
don't ever say that
so people were trying to speculate who
it was about
apparently people were saying it was
Cutie Cinderella and she's like I don't
know who this guy is
and then I think they figured out he was
her mod by the way they found out who it
was I don't know if I should say I know
who she is I mean I know of her
but she's a little I think she's an only
fans girl
that's kind of I wonder if that's like a
good orgasm though or if it's like it's
got to be like
[Music]
maybe this is the first time anyone else
has ever made an orgasm so for him it's
like sex
it feels like maybe they had sex
I mean look how proud he is I'm I mean
I'm making the Assumption here no whack
against the guy but this might have been
his first experience with the opposite
sex first time touching a girl yeah
first time touching a girl
first time hugging a girl that can't be
a girl
I'm I have no problem believing he's
never like kissed or
touched in us you know sexual way
I went up to her and hug her and I came
in my pants God I'd like to be there and
see that all down go down
like did he did he try to hide it did he
run away did she feel the moisture
during the hug I know it's gross but
these are things we have to think about
was he expressive I wonder did he yeah
did he have like a [__] face or a sound
did he make his own move
like imagine he I mean I assume his his
mouth was like by the streamer's ear
when he hugged her oh that makes me want
to die imagine he's like I just came in
my pants
oh I would KMS that is vile that is vile
but it's kind of sad for twitch mods
everywhere because here is a guy mod
who's modding for a girl and this man's
just out here being like yeah I came in
my pants when I smelled her hair
in another interview I'm reading that
he's admitted to doing this multiple
times
first time he met her he hugged her
another time at a party
wait he came in his bounce on different
he came in his pants on different
occasions yeah he's admitted to this
multiple times yeah okay so he's
planning if or I don't want to draw any
conclusions but this gets weird in my
opinion yeah if he if this is a
something that he's been doing then he's
like a sexual deviant right this is
deviancy
now apparently there's another video of
him talking about doing it before can we
pull that uh yeah I have let me see
I want to see if it gets claimed but
somebody said I can't control my goo
literally
that's literally him
did he do the ahigo face
oh my God she's got to feel so [__]
nasty about that that is so cool
somebody asks is that sexual harassment
I don't know what what do I don't know
it's violating as hell especially that
he's talking about it now
the fact that he did it a second time is
like okay what's going on here
once what's going once is a mistake
involuntary reaction yeah right I'm
trying to dig up the other video
um
he says in the first few seconds so I
think he'll be okay
but um what is there other stuff going
on here
taking a virgin twitch Sim to strip club
oh my god well there was what at one
time wait what the [__] is this built
different what is this video
it was linked in this dexarto article
okay this is built different when I met
St Pete she gave me a hug I met her the
first time and uh I ended up choosing my
pants
Okay so
okay so hold on what's the time
difference between these two clips are
we sure he's not talking about the same
thing
this is from a year ago later in the
video he talks about
um another time he was at a party and
the same thing happened
I will find that
I ended up leaving the convention going
back to my hotel room changing my
underwear and my pants and then going
back to the convention
I think one other time this was like why
are you saying this
what how do you think she's gonna feel
about this dude
like
I'm assuming you like
knowing her
She's Not Gonna Wanna [__] ever see
you dude if you keep coming in your
pants every time you smell her [__]
breath or whatever
this is so vile dude do not come
exactly it's that easy the Third
twitchcon
but this was like at a party when I was
drunk
dude why what is this face he's doing
the same face
he thinks he's cool or something I don't
know it's hard too I just came in my
isn't there a song about I just came in
my pants
I want to know what's different about
coming in your pants at a party when
you're drunk versus when you're at a
convention I'm waiting oh I need to know
it's all in the intro actually okay this
is great I mean this is phenomenal
it's an important distinction to be
honest I want to watch this whole video
how was he at the strip club
he needs to wear like a swimming you do
a special trick at the strip club
did you do his thing did he come his
pants at the strip club what I was
saying this man needs a wetsuit or a
swimsuit or something because he needs
to go from six to midnight my friend
who's nobody's got that much underwear
he's gonna have to bring a change of
underwear with him
although we did discuss this before when
a stripper called in and there are dudes
dudes be jizz in their pants in the
strip club come we established that
there's Malik on door watch
someone want to go test the um the door
he fixed yeah the baby's gonna go pop in
there and
give us an update on the door
yeah
well there was a bunch of girls dancing
up on me and then I just I
oh [__] there's a video of it holy [__]
holy [__] yeah no not of the moment is
it it's looked like okay hold on I hope
not this dude is speechless by the way
which is
okay here's a b
go ahead
closing the door looks seamless looks
clean
opening and there it is wow did you lock
it there it is
he's gonna lock it this time
it fell off
is that did that fall off
okay
it's questionable craftsmanship
[Music]
did the handle fall off baby
I don't think he can hear it very well
over there
yeah we need the handle to stay on Malik
that's part of the deal explained that
he said he can explain that's part of
the deal dude the handle needs to stay
on
[Music]
wait what happened Amy
I don't think he's done so Jeremiah was
in there and I shut it I was like and he
goes oh be funny if we got locked in
here I was like and I did that and the
door door handle came off Malik said
it's a manufacturer
defect he said he can explain
[Music]
he said we need to return that one the
handle's defective
he says defective he says he's putting
believe it or not the handle is actually
defective
one in a million he says
he says it's a one in a million
that's awesome I believe him
we should put him on blast
who made that handle and Malik wants a
crusade against the handle manufacturers
Universal Hardware is being called out
by Malik
one in a million that's a UA handle
Universal
Hardware that's so funny although to be
fair he fixed the other ones so yeah
it's a Hampton product it's a it's a
Hampton product is it is it possible a b
broke it
he does break door
he says no here it is door hardware
let's view the door hardware
no reviews zero Stars not until now one
star broke
defective one in a million kids
you think it's a heavy duty commercial
curved or uh have any commercial flat
lever what do you keep going down he I
remember ours had the key oh with the
deadbolt combo yeah I think it's that
one the deadbolt combo
interesting
yeah it's okay I'm I'm good
yeah we're gonna we're leaving a review
Malik okay hell yeah we're writing we're
giving it one star and which one is this
the uh heavy duty uh read the name to
Malik Dan uh
what was it it was the uh
heavy duty lever Deadpool combo heavy
you got that
heavy duty lever deadbolt combo
what are you doing it's actually just a
handle a passage handle
just the handle not a combo okay loving
the the Ambiance of of shouting a
conversation across the studio okay so
maybe it's just this thing maybe just a
heavy duty commercial
that's a one star handle
absolutely defective
or maybe to be fair we could say bot
three one was defective
you know what I mean my [__] broke
brought three of them one was defective
you know they're not going to publish it
if you write [__]
about three of them one was defective I
heard it's like a one in a million thing
still why me
why me
all right I'm over it let's keep
watching this guy
this guy's my this guy rules in a
weirdly [__] up way
he rolls in the same way the murder porn
guy does
maybe they should get a congregation
together should we have a group calling
yeah group calling sounds pretty
interesting yeah to be honest I would
like to talk to him too okay not as a
group
separate groups I need to focus on one
at a time yeah I'd love to I'd like to
talk to him
yeah
there was a bunch of girls dancing up on
me and then I just I
yeah
[Music]
that's that's badass Dallas Galley oh so
that that's her I guess they're showing
her
uh
why is Dallas banned are you in love
with me where is two hundred dollars
first well he's been a mod for several
um twitch streamers so what is this
compilation exactly he's gonna enjoy it
so much that people reading his name
oh that's his name yeah like what is
Dallas's o face look like that's what I
wonder it's probably like are they all
talking about this
yeah well this is a year ago so I don't
know if they're talking about different
they all know this guy's coming his
pants I guess he's got it according to
this article he's known as twitch's
biggest simp
and he was a regular minimum twitch's
biggest female streamers broadcasts
said I couldn't buy pants in public once
never made a face so this is kind of his
thing
this is his claim to fame
Dallas Galley I'm the dude that use my
pants it's a special trick oh
thank you I feel like I was there
I'm Dallas I have a lot of questions I
really want to
psychoanalyze this I want to get
I don't want to just know about the
coming in the pants I want to know why
they come in the pants I want to know
was there planning in the [__] in the
pants how many times have we done this
does he come other ways
hmm
scally I'm a 27 year old virgin and I'm
built different that's for sure
I'm very well known by a lot of people
yeah
why do you think he genuinely thinks
okay I see what's going on here
this is his claim to fame he's obsessed
with twitch streamers they're all famous
this is he's known for this he likes
being known for something at least it's
not murder
that's why a lot of serial killers do it
this has just a Serial pants gizzard
which is a lot better
porn that murder porn
that is
I don't know because of the things that
I say subscribe to Pornhub now do you
watch porn at all
uh no I'm a very unique individual stop
that hey there Haley what's it like in
minutes
[Music]
or is that him
hear what people think about you no not
really
[__] man what the hell
Fifty Shades of Gray I love it
girlfriend
friend Dean horny and don't fap is
torture I want to die oh my God
[__] having a sex drive sometimes I wish
I was asexual
can't do this man would be like a
physicist working on the highest level
of science if this man was asexual
Harvard PhD in astrophysics instead he's
just coming in his pants by hugging
streamers those eggshells
hey uh
uh reach what does it sound like when
you come in your pants
oh squeaking that's not okay all right
you got me
[Music]
now do the one where he goes
that's what it sounds like do anything
right now because of my erection
[__] you five inch dick
go down
you horny piece of [__]
what was going through your mind when
you sent that uh well do you sub to any
only fans at all uh no so why are you so
why is he lying he's so honest but now
he's lying to us
to be honest I haven't been in a
relationship in like 10 years uh haven't
really done anything with a girl in like
that long so it's probably why when was
the last time you masturbated when I was
17.
bro no way
well if this is true no wonder he's
walking around Jizzy I guess that would
explain the physiology of it a little
bit but like why how could he
this dude who is apparently tweeting
about how horny is not masturbate it's
not possible
does [__] in your pants count
no
technically well
what is this just a compilation of his
cute pics this is from his that's just
his Instagram because I was scrolling
through to see if it's safe for work it
is if you just want to go to his
instance
pretty Epic
I don't believe it why don't you just
jerk off because like obviously
you not doing that is not helping
anybody
we need you jerking off
it's just it's better for everybody
oh my God this dude [__] in his pants
20 times this day
but if you scroll down he does a lot of
these who's gonna hug you bro yeah it's
a lot of these like laying in bed shots
a little bit further down
oh my God
ooh mid-sleep I used to hit those in
Middle School
is he coming in every photo I'm confused
no
only son he seems like a type of dude
that just likes any attention so I I
think he'll be happy with this and also
to call him I would really like to ask
him questions I think he's gonna watch
isn't bust a nut yeah please don't
virtual e-jack
wow pretty repetitive Feud there's so
many it's real interesting I see
announcing he's going live or something
yeah he's on switch okay that's what's
going on here
that explains it at least a little bit
so I haven't seen him with a girl but he
must have [__] his pants on this one
like holy [__] that was like his Super
Bowl
it's just recent too right
he might even be touching no this one's
a little bit older
oh let me read this I was so lucky to
not only know but meet two of the ladies
who have helped motivate me and kept me
staying positive in life
that's one way to put coming in your
pants
thank you to these two ladies for not
only being a positive influence on me in
life but always being such kind friends
very lucky to not only know two of the
nicest but prettiest ladies from
everywhere in my room you don't always
have my support and love for everything
about you you both have really helped me
in becoming a better person okay that's
nice
post not clarity
yeah the guy in the background the back
left looks like he might have just
busted and not too left I must say that
I've had some post-coital regrets about
that phrase
some pictures he looks like handsome and
fine
I feel like if this guy just put get his
[__] together a little bit he would be
like have no problem
you know
that's the thing with all these in cells
it's like most of these in cells are not
like hideous irredeemable like
not 100 pack of nostradam looking
[__]
there you go normal looking like not
worse like you know I if I did something
with this face
it's it's possible for everybody
oh I'm being told this is actual that's
his actual face I'm so sorry Ethan yeah
I mean listen people are making jokes
about how ugly I am I'm a punchline
so if I can do it you could do it
think
just stop nodding oh [__] here's another
one with a girl oh no she has no idea
she has no idea it's fully Jack right
there are we sure that's not a family
member at Christmas all right well let
me read oh spend some time with my mom
oh that's sick
his mom's kind of hot
listen sometimes and you know I'm not
even gonna say that joke
mom I want a vape I spent some time with
my mom today I always enjoy the time I
spent with my family admit I'm worried
that when I move away my mom was going
to struggle without me
foreign
not in like a sexual way but I'm just
saying like there was some coddling that
happened in here that really
put this ban on a path of
uh would you say Norman Bates of uh
Jackie okay
yeah I'm done watching it by the way
all the poor all the comments are about
spunking his pants now damn it
but that's why you don't go around
bragging about this stuff
all right I went up to her I hug her and
I came in my pants
I think that's a cherished memory for
him
[Music]
I I I I gotta know why this guy I'm not
gonna lie what I don't get good vibes
from this guy no no no of course not but
I do want to talk to him I want why are
you not masturbating
why do you want to talk to him well okay
let's because like listen Jordan
Peterson can't be the only one reaching
out to men and across the world you know
we need to be these positive uh role
model for these disenfranchises
like dude though like he's clearly you
want him to go black pilled or you want
him to come back to the light
I don't know he just seems like a big
attention seeker to me I think I know
that being into it because he just wants
to be famous but he also seems honest to
a fault which is good for someone that I
want to talk I think he's lying about a
lot of stuff too though like you you
said so yourself he's definitely lying
about not being subscribed to girls only
fans and like maybe he's telling the
truth though would that be interesting
if he doesn't masturbated in 10 years I
think he's lying
I personally am fascinated I I
understand everything you're saying and
I proceed with caution by the way this
is his happy Mother's Day post
yeah does that include your hot mom
the next post I sent is for Dan
for me for you he's talking to you
you might have a future with James
Charles if he's willing to go that route
armpit hair
of that
good for him
uh here's another one
why is this one for Dan
because the caption working hard but
getting very little sleep but feeling
better haters gonna hate but nothing's
stopping me
that's Dan you're a hater and I'm here
to help the fact that nothing's stopping
you is what makes you so creepy
maybe less motivated yeah no maybe think
about stopping actually
consider it
Dan this guy's gonna call into Rich Lux
I personally would love to talk to this
guy I hear what you're saying but he's
so fascinating
we could tell if he's lying why is he
fascinating he's not fascinating he is
what do you find fascinating about
everything I've been talking about
already okay well we we clearly disagree
on this
I need to talk to him would you find the
murder porn guy fascinating
I don't want to talk to that guy I do
we already said we're reaching out all
right that's you
don't worry you don't have to talk you
can mute your mic
and you're here at phones you don't have
to listen
God damn I'm so [__] hot he said
murder porn
yeah I mean you do look you look do look
decent that's why
this whole thing is so odd
giving a pro Jared
give him something
you know I just realized Pro Jared looks
like
um
who's the Muppet baby with the hook nose
Gonzo yeah he looks like Gonzo Pro Jared
I thought you're gonna he looks more
like um
[Music]
he strikes me more of a as a um
as a beaker yeah
he looks like Pro Jared and Bryce Hall
few because he's very he's very narrow
and and
long you know what I mean I see that
reminds me of this guy but I'm telling
you Pro Jared was [__] everybody dude
and I'm not calling him ugly or anything
because I would never do that but
he's definitely got an interesting look
I can say that
do you see the the the do you see the
Gonzo I I do I do I still I see more
beakers still but I see what you're
talking about
Jared he's a [__] man
what was his uh private Discord
challenge
oh my God
send Jerry man
it's still such a mystery to me that
people forgave him
that's so weird it's completely forgiven
yeah everyone will turn in all the
commentary shows like we were wrong we
apologize everybody needs to apologize
to Pro Jared I even don't remember why
Dan
he's crushing it though good for him
send Jared
sin Jared
well
we could do a poll should we do a poll
maybe people don't want to talk to him
I think I mean if you want to talk to
him and talk to him I just it could be
fun interesting yeah let's go easy he is
fascinating there's when have you ever
met someone like him Dan
I mean a guy who jizz is in his pants
all the time and talks about it openly I
guess I haven't met one
there you go bada bing bada boom I was
happy keeping it that way but if you're
gonna invite him on then it's a gold
mine Daniel
uh what did you you want me to ask if
people
want the pants chasing guy yeah past
choosing guy and then the murderer do
you want what do you want Ethan to talk
to the Panthers and guys yeah do you
want anything to talk to the pants
[__] guy
yes no Blair winter said I feel like
some of these e-girl super fans lie
about being virgins and hope that they
do a fa fan video who does that
f a fan
by the way I have no trouble believing
that guy's version by the way either
it's not like
f a fan
I just found out he has a only fans
it's all a gimmick oh then that's why
it's not interesting it's all a gimmick
it's like why does it lie wait okay okay
he found his way it's just like it's
this it's the clout hunger once again is
just like these people will go to any
lengths to be famous and like even if
it's extremely embarrassing it's like oh
I can be the guy who jizzes in his pants
you made me defend this but you're kind
of explaining Jimmy Lee too no obviously
the sexual I also don't want you to meet
him we know this but it's interesting
yeah I know GB is interesting yeah yeah
dare say it doesn't Jimmy really doesn't
like borderline sexually assault people
he just verbally I beg to differ were
you with me in that Deli
it just it's just not yeah it's not that
he's a creep though he is again it's
just
it just seems like he's just trying to
be just another person doing whatever
they can to get famous so here's the
thing he has an only fan so he's
definitely lying
yeah it's yeah that's that's a
he's just a [__] Cloud Goblin dude
the whole thing could just be made up
too frankly it's just a way to get
attention well maybe he's only fans well
hold on what kind of content the fact
that he's on the website at all
he's definitely you know what I mean he
goes I haven't looked at porn in 10
years you're you have an only fans
account
right that's like literally it stretches
believability a little bit doesn't it oh
he just did he just donate that's him no
no this is just oh okay here's a message
he says I will now be doing custom vids
and picks treasure it would be 25 per
pick and 100 per customer video DME
should we get him to do one for us
that would be kind of epic
somebody said coming for cloud yeah
exactly the dude he found his angle he's
coming for cloud somebody said Jimmy Lee
is extremely nuanced I agree I need that
clout he's three-dimensional he's
four-dimensional what about him he's
definitely more interesting than this
guy I don't know if maybe looking at his
Amazon wish list will that change your
mind or potentially I want to see his
wish list is it safe for work how did
you come across that I'm going in deep I
just have it on can I look at this uh
the first page you can oh my God so he
wants he wants his sugar daddies okay
hold on hold on hold on oh my God
anything yeah okay yeah no there's one
item on here that's a little
he just wants guys got Grandpa feeling a
little frisky he got rock band he wants
a camera yeah it was all like very it
was like Pokemon and then ew dude wait
show this
Pokeman fashion cute girl pillow
bro you're [__] that's just too far
all right take it off I'm gonna go down
he wants Pokemon plushie set
slim fit rip destruction jeans skinny
jeans
a big screen TV
is that I don't see any other that's it
oh I think you you missed it
where's the one I missed um it'd be item
number four
one two three four heavy duty luggage
slashing strap holder
or bulky items
I thought that was something yeah I'm
clicking it I don't know that's just no
it's not I was mistaken it's just an
innocent item
okay you guys in the clear well anyway
the people have spoken they think he is
not worthy of the call it's looking
close but it does look like a no always
all right fans of Dallas get your votes
in
wait is this a poll between uh the
murder porn dude or no no no it's just
um interesting uh Super Chat from Sydney
I went to high school with the murder
porn dude and he was a bully not gonna
lie yeah I mean he's a psychopath it's
like we just watched it we just watched
him barge into someone's house and [__]
on them in their own home
he's worse than a bully apparently he
killed people I was bullied well you're
kind of like vaguely alluded to it
bowling's the least [__] worst thing
he's done in his life yeah I wish he was
just a bully
all right so let's wrap up the jizz and
the pants guy then all right all right
but now let's go to murder porn guy I
was
I was trying to stay quiet because I
didn't wanna
throw water on your excitement for it
it's okay but listen he just does he
just seems like he's I'm just I'm not
playing Goblin dude he's goblining I
think I'm a man
I think you guys are underestimating
how good that conversation could be and
remember you can always turn it off we
could always hang up you know what I
mean I Dan I don't mean to go against
you here I agree with Ethan though I
think it'd be a very fascinating
conversation listen yeah this is Ethan
show if he wants to talk to the jizz
pants guy
he's more than welcome to it's just that
was just well listen no I'm a man of the
people if people don't want to watch it
well sometimes the people don't know
what they want
once they hear the joke guys talk sure
then they go wow this is this guy's
amazing we've had I don't know we've had
many conversations with you know uh what
what traditional Society my damn
deviance on the show and it's been a
wonderful time I love the Seaman Collins
you know what I mean like I got no
problem with it on face value but
I just
The Vibes are just off with this one I
don't know okay let's let's all I can
say let's move on to the murder porn guy
and see if that one shakes it because
dude yeah if you guys say no to both
then then I'm just gonna have to make my
own decisions right do you you don't
want me on Ethan to talk to the murder
porn
guy I know you're going to be annoyed
with me saying this but really if it's
between those two definitely the jizz
pantsing guy
oh really over the murder guy oh guys it
seems dangerous I gotta heavily disagree
with that we need the murderer
absolutely that's like getting a chance
to talk to like um Charles Manson yeah
exactly he's like leaving a call The
Other Guys the FBI is going to Anna
analyze our [__] interview with him
[__] it let's do it in person [__] it
I'm curious what's the downside down
according to you all right I'm throwing
up I'm throwing up the murder porn guy
that interview would definitely be in a
true crime documentary like yeah that's
what I was that's all I've been thinking
so far the murder porn guys looking more
promising
what's the downside according to you
Donna he comes and kills us yeah no I
mean like that's literally just pants
guy is just embarrassing this is like a
whole nother [__] level although you
never know you never know damages Bay
and Sky could be the one killing people
you just know it's always the quiet one
it's true you never know you never know
people said Ted uh Kaczynski was a
charmer
right
you said statistically somebody in this
room may have killed somebody at some
point statistically
I just that cannot be true
you're telling me 10 of all people are
murderers
[Laughter]
percent
of USA population has committed murder
those are the ones we know about Ethan
we should add Manchester Does it include
like
War I gotta ask Chachi because someone
has chechi beta
yeah
excluding War excluding War exclu well
that's I think Dan was considering that
ugly you're disgusting yeah what
percentage of people have
War does not count it definitely we're
talking about in society
because that's like you know that's like
that kind of murder is like cool
murder that's the sanction that's the
cool stuff oh Ted Bundy is who I met
yeah my bad
um well people are in favor of the
murder porn guys so let's continue with
that reaching out
the logic in our side is so funny like
yeah not the guy not not the install but
the guy that murders people that guy
bring him on
chappie GPT has nothing
we need to be more specific what did you
ask it well first I said what percentage
of uh people have killed someone and
then excluding war war percentage what
population it's obviously gonna I was
joking like yes it's gonna be like point
zero one percent or something well I'm
actually curious now you got you sent me
down a path and what now you want me to
turn away
let me try asking it how many people be
killing uh people are very down for the
murder porn yeah there's it's a more
enthusiastic yes than it was a no for
the pantsches all right so we'll start
there if you guys love the murder porn
guy then maybe we can move out move on
to the jerk off jizz guy
there's more of a mystery there there's
more to unravel the jerk off jizz guy
for lack of a better term already blew
his load of interest you know what I
mean we know it you jump the shark he
came his pants we know what we know the
story of this I feel like I could have
an interesting combo with him but what
do I know I would like to see that
all right all right well there it is in
sales or so 2022 that's right we're
moving on to just straight up [__]
cult leaders on this if you're gonna be
an Intel you might as well kill him
while you're at it all right we don't
like people who half measure
no half measures
all right let's watch some no half
centers no half centers we have centers
in this house uh wait ricegum reacts to
a clip of meeting a b is that right yeah
holy [__] I'm a human face rug
wait is this recent
uh this yeah he recently reacted to this
I think like a week ago but this
happened at twitchcon I remember when it
happened you told us about it so you
weren't lying I just assumed you were
lying
that's why I walked back I was like I
gotta get this [__] on camera oh yeah
you did you film it I don't remember
dreamers live of course
what's up dude see I'm so nice I said yo
look at me from behind guys yo guys am I
drippy
okay you were kind of fanboying oh yeah
because I'm just I'm walking down the
street and I see ricegum you're like
what's up bro
no that's what I was saying what up to
him and I'm like oh yeah I work for
Ethan I work for H3 oh that's uh okay
I'm so nice I said hi yo look at me from
behind guys yo guys am I drippy this
phase wrong are you drippy you're just
wearing a white hoodie what the [__] are
you talking about
not at all you want to see drip
Ela bought me these sandals
I did notice the new shoes
keep backing up keep backing up a little
more and by the way
now nobody's gonna be in here calling me
short because I'm based usually I'm
barefoot in here practically now I got
some real shoes on and I'm towering over
everybody Ethan walked out of the
bathroom tight looks at me and goes
what's up bro and I'm like What's Up
didn't realize what he was doing but he
was taller I'm like oh I'm hella tall
even Zach was looking kind of small to
me okay look at the grip on those bad
boys dude oh you can go off-roading and
[__] oh yeah dude you just put you make
them a little tighter and you're ready
for a marathon your foot has that extra
it has that extra strap so it doesn't
fall off yeah the table yeah
how many doors are going to kick in with
those
you know what I was thinking it'd be
funny if someone went and broke the Dory
fixed right now no I
um
got it what's wrong with that idea
I thought it was funny
AV you feeling it I had the feeling in
my back in my head that you might do
that if I'm being honest I'm not doing
it
but once they fix it that you might just
go knock it down
all right let's see let's watch this
how are you yo is slow mode on yo yo can
we turn off slomo thank you nice to meet
you
guys okay
yo why is rug now look guys guys I just
got exposed bad all right you guys look
at this all right some fan came up look
at rug he's hella nice look at rug how
are you thank you nice to meet you this
is so weird he's just like randomly
reacting to your footage yeah what is
how did this come today
this is clipped on my twitch Channel
maybe someone sent it in his Discord I
didn't see the full stream I just saw
this on our subreddit but yeah I don't
know he's just that's so random but yeah
I could like when I saw him that day I
could tell he was a little jumpy which
is weird because it was just me and Lena
and then he was with like a whole group
of people but he kind of talks about
being nervous of the uh the Ops at the
time but he didn't really acknowledge
that I said I worked for you so I found
that surprising let me finish this
Dylan nice to meet you look at me bro my
face got a straight face on look you
guys have to look at my energy versus
rugs energy yeah look how are you thank
you
uh yeah rug seems like a great guy rug's
a king rug does seem very nice yeah you
you correctly identified that
[Music]
um
smiling I'm out here looking yo I was
scared yo I was scared of the Ops bro I
swear they're gonna look at me bro I'm
looking around and my eyes big like
little dirt type [__] so rock smiling he
got no Ops rug got no Ops me I have to
watch my back you don't worry no
there's Noah
there's no Ops for Rice gum
okay that's so random huh
Kanye and his new wife did you guys know
he got married like married the so oh my
God now what
it's an abomination
so the shoulder pads thing is kind of a
what and the tights holy [__] this man
was like I want a look that's [__] up
as possible
the tights the tights into the shoe
the like sock Shoe Right it looks like a
Roblox
and then this here is quite interesting
[__] sick dude so it's like a turd
about poking out of the butthole
see wearing like hockey pads too or like
football pads
yo your shoulder's that big
you look good
I'm glad everybody
hates him now
now what I'm just really glad
is that a true statement everybody hates
him I mean not everybody obviously but
a baby anywhere near the popularity that
he was a few years ago definitely not
Babble and reach are like yo this guy's
spitting facts y'all should be listening
closely
[Music]
uh
uh this [__] is crazy
I don't know why the [__] you would do
this
oh my God why oh my God this [__]
video bro this is not better than
shaving who told you this was better
than shaving
oh no
yeah
[__] no that was so painful he's like
bleeding I think when they take it off I
would not do this
oh look at that oh
my God man
there's no Escape I mean
there's only one way out of that
murder porn is this murder porn oh my
God
dude why why why he's in a barber shop
this is like a service they offer
oh why oh
okay
I can't watch anymore
it's so uncomfortable
I hate it
and I'm out
about you Dan if I get down to 180 can
we wax your face 180 yeah that's my
target weight
let's let's deal with the let's one step
at a time we'll we'll talk after the
Mayo okay we set up a new Benchmark
though for 180. Dan should Mayo up that
now the thing is the Mayo thing is like
humiliating kind of gross but it doesn't
hurt
wait a b you would do that I'd do it for
the show you would yeah I almost feel
bad I mean I do want to see it but it
looks so painful give me pain anytime
over eating [__] I will I will go
through anything interesting but we'd
have to we'd have to probably trim your
beard right because that would be super
painful to do it yeah you wouldn't want
to do it with the full beard [__] it do
it all right I wonder if you know I do
not care about pain I just I don't like
eating [__]
I
mean people get waxed all the time on
like sensitive areas on your face on
your cheeks it's so funny I mean the
skin is so sensitive there like the skin
is sensitive uh hello Dan I know like
people get like Brazilians or whatever
but uh still I don't know maybe I'm
wrong maybe it's not a big [__] one
seems like that would be I mean yeah
painful Jamie gooch
so Amy I wonder if it'd be less painful
with the beard at full length I think it
wouldn't stick at all it wouldn't work
as well
a little bit Yeah if you have like a lot
of beer it would like be would not pull
off well before you get waxed you have
to trim your hair yeah that was my
understanding too you would want to use
like Clippers to just buzz it down so
that they're still stubble and then you
use the wax to rip it out I mean if
you're down you know I'll do it I think
it'd be but God I feel bad
yeah you do it
180 Lena are you here
yep I'm here what do you think about
that I think it'd be fun oh my God it's
a joker brain what the [__] love that
all right let's do it let's be Lena by
the wax
let's do it after pregnancy or 180. you
wanna do it after the break yeah because
I don't want to go home with a [__] up
face okay I'll hold off
this is your Rodeo
hey this British kid set his whole yard
on fire sounds interesting
I was going bro bro you are why oh my
god oh why do people do this
kids are so dumb
it's like it's going wait why they throw
what the hell wait who did that oh my
God everything was fine until they
kicked it at the house
that was the Turkish fire brigade
trying to put out that fire it's getting
worse
what happened at the fence now the fence
is on fire
like you would have thought that they
would understand not to kick it anymore
huh
this is what happens when you get bored
as a kid man
bad things oh my Lord
let me see that one more time yeah see
it's like okay cool you got it
right there why are you going back in
for more well his Cannon's on fire he
drops it that's fine
but now at this point why they both went
to kick it at the same time they both
had that idea isn't that weird and then
homie comes kicks it at the [__]
house it's the best
was this their goal
is this like a jackass thing insurance
fraud I don't know Insurance Friday boy
Lightning Lawn on fire oh yeah
so we get it Apple we got hunger we got
Malik fixing our doors mysterious water
bottle
what is this dude I saw this
I'm not conspiracy person you guys know
that about me
but I saw this and was like yo that's
pretty sketch look at this
as always the leads doing
the usual nothing to worry about now bro
I'm not I don't think they're drinking
like baby blood or whatever the [__]
you're implying if anything he's just
drinking like steroids or something okay
okay watch watch
can we play this
yeah yeah I didn't get going all right
so here's these dudes in the purple
shirt
they're putting together a drink okay
you'll see it it'll make sense took a
bottle out of his bag
he's doing it like pretty shady down
there in the ground
putting stuff in it pouring it in a
different bottle
adding stuff
there's like three of them
oh now the guy in front of them is
involved
[Music]
there's four of them oh they're covering
up then a fifth one behind them so now
they pass this bottle forward to the
ball girl
who runs it over
oh to the player
who drinks it
look at this
[Music]
now at the same time
that's pretty Brazen it's not that
sneaky
but it's pretty bizarre don't you think
like what the [__] I think the music
definitely enhances the uh creepy Factor
Why is there five dudes sitting look how
stressed out he looks yeah the way they
were covering that [__] up too doesn't
make any sense why would they be doing
it from the stands
and then they got the ball girl on the
on the lamp on the cut I mean
[Music]
and he's like yeah I know what that is
the blood of God what could be in a
beverage that would enhance your
performance
you know I don't know
cocaine amphetamine oh yeah things
adrenochrome adrenal yeah I mean that
seems like the most likely thing is that
they're trying to get around the drug
testing
probably test before the game and then
they'd smuggle it in that way by having
the uh
though at the same time yeah they gotta
know there's like a ton of cameras on
them they handed it to the ball girl
people were just like some random
cell phone camera right there right that
was yeah but I mean
I thought they were being slick here's
some details about it uh November 2022
Novak was in semi-finals round of the
Paris Masters tennis open the game was
tied
Novak asked for a drink from the bench
uh
okay so Ulysses badio his
physiotherapist began to prepare it in
the stands
yeah it was caught on video physical
trainer Marco panichi then appeared to
warm his colleague to be more discreet
while making the drink
the drink apparently worked as he went
on to win the semi-final
the drink did it
so what's in the bottle even though
people are skeptical of what might be in
the bottle
is most likely some type of dietary
supplement
July 2022 during Wimbledon tennis
matches people were asking the same
question about what's in Novak's bottle
during his final rounds of the match he
was seen gesturing with his bottle to
his coach's box before tipping it up and
squeezing it into his mouth let me see
that
this is deep
here he is
in his bottle he needs more we need more
of whatever that was
why would they need to mix it there
wait what the right
what
why is he breathing into it what is he
doing was it like a gas
he was huffing yeah that didn't yeah
that for sure seemed like he was
inhaling not drinking well he's telling
them I need more it's weirder okay let
me watch this
because I need more
he definitely inhaled
it was just trying to get the last drops
yeah maybe that was very weird you hold
it upside down if you're trying to get
dropped yeah I feel like that's
in terms of physics that's not then he
goes in for another Huff
s gamer Subs yeah gamer Subs would win
you a match
dude that's so [__] weird
here's another clip that says everyone
should watch this footage
if you're interested in this
oh God 15 minutes
Jesus Christ
[Music]
I know first they've got all the
receipts in this
good thing should I watch this it's kind
of epic
I'm invested [__] it or I'll just put on
times two
[Music]
and we it doesn't have audio which I
love
oh no I had the mics down I think it
does yeah keep the conspiracy music
going then so the intros slate says this
video shows a very suspicious behavior
of Novak since 2018 what I'm about to
show you are some clips starting with
Wimbledon 2022 capturing drinking from
bottles given to him from his team live
during matches a few games after
drinking from those bottles Novak came
back to life his tennis is air free and
his physicality goes through the roof
he does it over and over and over again
okay
okay uh
we're on to you dude
[Music]
this is one we saw
he's definitely huffing man he's also
the number one tennis player in the
world
he is yeah no back joke's massive let's
see he's got to be under so much
scrutiny then
I think there's a reasonable explanation
but I'm
he's done this before where he's huffing
from the water
see he's currently number three but in
the past he was number one idiot why is
he huffing from the bottle
that is so odd
he receives a towel yes a towel strange
right
here's a towel for you sir
okay what's in the towel
towels are provided by the tournament
why would you need your own towel this
one might be a stretch
he Novak's a weird guy like whenever he
did would win Wimbledon he would eat a
piece of the grass
like he's got weird quirks and [__]
we're superstitions
like myself yes the towel thing
we can see the same drink behavior in
Rome
we got our eyes on you Novak
maybe he's just OCD actually and does
all these like different rituals it's
quite possible
um he was notoriously they wouldn't let
him into certain tournaments because he
did not believe in getting vaccinated
okay he was that I heard about that yeah
he's like bro I don't take vaccine hell
no I just [__] shoot steroids up my
gooch adrenochrome oh my gooch
it hits fast there
I think gooch
you think you're doing too much with
this video
here 2019
quarterfinals
decision suspicious Behavior
okay so here's his team once again
preparing a special bottle why is it
suspicious that
this is us this video is making him look
innocent yeah this is I mean this whole
thing is [__] dumb as [__] I'm sorry
okay hater ass I thought
why are we did you just see this Tick
Tock and get spooked by it like where no
I thought it would no I was no I wasn't
spooked by it I was just like it looks
like he's cheating
look why would they be so secretive yeah
it is interesting why why are six people
hiding it like not this video but the
initial one Ethan saw it is like what
the [__] going on
well again they both stood up like right
in front of the thing then mixing it
it's like the kids are watching though
there's like two kids there watching
what's happening
look carefully he's using tape to attach
a drinking straw it's [__] Crystal
Light what does that matter
what's with the straw
why is he wearing a jacket
that with the hat there for come on Dan
that's a lanyard on now it's time to
pass it
okay
down to the uh
I mean the judges are seeing it yeah
it's like this is totally a normal part
of the game it's it's one thousand
percent they're not being that discreet
they literally just did it right behind
the judge the judge told him where to
hand it yeah
he's in on it too
I do want to know what's in the bottle
though to be honest it's probably some
proprietary concoction is why they don't
want people seeing dietary supplement
why would he do no I mean this this is
top level Elite athletes like the maybe
they have some [__] maybe it is baby
blood in there and I don't want people
to know magic algae yeah it's the
adrenochrome from a special River
okay they're going back in for the
mystery bottle
why is he holding it down so low look
now he's going to the backpack
brief frame
freeze it
almost freeze it yeah okay so if you
look closely here enhance
I think I can actually see
right here
yeah don't don't look at the bottom
right people just be looking at my mouse
up here
I think he I think he came in his pants
okay you know what do that doesn't that
look like a little just stand right
there is this lemonade gamer stuff
it is not
it came in the bottle
oh it's that's gamer sup right
yeah this is some old stuff shooter
I think that was from the water talk you
guys are supposed to say yes
yes yes too late now
wait no
we don't waste water bottles with Gamers
up so we we use these baby that's true
yeah
already ready to go already mentioned
this man is doing spoonfuls or some [__]
dude what the [__] spoonfuls
yeah that protein powder that probably
tastes so [__] gross
it's a mod semen that's what makes it a
schizo video that we found like what
this is this like blue swirl territory
to be totally honest this is making him
look more innocent yeah
the further down the rabbit hole we go
the less suss any of this is
I think he might just be OCD or
something there's an explanation for
this video uh below okay oh because
people speculate that what he was
squeezing into his mouth was not water
the
similar situation occurred 2020 as uh he
jokingly dismissed questions about it at
the time saying his bottle contained a
magic potion
they're in the Q a post-match Novak was
asked about what was in the bottle many
professional players have been opting to
take unmixed energy supplements
or isotonic powder during matches
apparently mixing supplement without
water gives more of a buzz
it's weird
just doing rails of [__]
just it's just railing Gamers up let's
go wait here's the thing if he's really
cheating even the Press is asking him
like they would know they would know
he's innocent I think I think we can put
this one to bed he's innocent okay such
an extraordinary like athlete like I I
love watching him play like he's just
unbelievable big tenant oh you are kind
of a business guy aren't you yeah
members go up thank you so much for the
200.200
.
[Applause]
that's awesome thank you so much DPI
there it is
okay so he's uh he's innocent he's
innocent
this guy I've been wanting to talk about
I don't we don't have a lot of time but
there's this guy um
Secret mizzy
who we talk about people doing anything
for cloud I mean this is like that gone
gone wrong
um he was banned on tick tock
I'm surprised he hasn't been banned on
YouTube what the [__] taking them so
long
check out what this guy does
this is one of several insane videos
[Music]
oh it's on Tick Tock oh God Tick Tock
has like simultaneously the strictest
and the most insanely
[Applause]
um
[Music]
yeah there's kids there is this where
the study group is
this no
investors in America he'd be dead
man oh you got kids
it's just so [__] up
okay so that's just one though epic it's
a pattern of behavior we're talking
about here he is stealing a woman's dog
say what
that sounds super funny
look as he walked into a random house to
harass the people living there and stole
their dog sorry you got a nice dog
I think
[Music]
I think uh
I think that's I think you can murder
someone for that every single time like
genuinely I think there's a lot about
staying your ground about with if
someone takes your puppy you can murder
porn
that is insane
then
video of him ripping up books in the
library super funny
that's awesome because you can just say
just kidding but you destroyed boom
we're in the library hey I'm gonna drag
in it why is this guy not banned from
tick tock
oh hey I said but the minute I mentioned
James Charles
I get suspended for two months
in front of the people that I [__] him
let's just do it any book I come come
come on
I'm sorry I'm at school
excuse me what kind of um get a book
here
oh
hey you're right yeah fine thank you um
[Applause]
all right okay just one minute
um
it's not really funny it's like
disturbing
do these videos get views on tick tock
does this man have fans
let's see he's been arrested actually
for videos bothering people on the
street and entering homes without
permission the Metropolitan Police have
confirmed that they've arrested the 18
year old
in London on suspicion of causing a
public nuisance
oh he's banned on Tick Tock Hallelujah
so does this guy have any Outlet
he did an interview I don't care
oh he says this I'm a black male doing
these things that's why there's such an
uproar on the internet
nice I don't fake my pranks but I always
make sure to sort out the situation you
just ripped up a book How You Gonna sort
that out
but none of my pranks have malicious
intention dude what
oh my God what a [__]
the judge ordered mizzy to not directly
or indirectly post videos on the social
media without documented consent of the
people featured in the content that he
must not trespass into private property
and they must not attend the Westfield
Mall in Stratford
and he also has to pay 400 that's pretty
light
you could still make videos he appeared
on Piers Morgan the hell
this interview is crazy yeah but like
every interview is done he's been kicked
out of
well I'm not surprised by that it's kind
of his thing
let's see I'm sorry didn't it it's a
movement but what's something what's the
movie deep down being free I'm not
letting anyone tell you nothing that's
why I can deal with this stuff I have
I'm the most hated person on the
internet right now no
no no no
yes exactly stay in it whatever you say
most people watches will have never
heard of you where are you from well now
they are that you just put it to me
they'll just look at the way you're
behaving now and I think yeah he's a
complete [__] I don't know why Piers
Morgan thought this would be an
interesting debate
let's bring on the kid that like steals
puppies and rips up library books and
debate him about if his videos are good
or not
compete movement he should have did a
poll I mean this is like Pierce is the
latest Mo we've kind of noticed this
development in the last year or so like
he just brings on shitty people and then
berates them I brought on today a
murderer I'm gonna debate him if murder
is Justified or not
to me we're not trying to talk because
you keep talking this animated manner
trying to stop me asking you any
questions and then you say is it because
I'm black is it somehow here's Pierce
Morgan in a fierce debate with the 18
year old degenerate
good job Pierce stunning uh he was
arrested again for violating the court
order that was issued just a few days
previous the Metropolitan Police asked
said on Friday 26 May officers arrested
eight-year-old man again
of Suspicion of breach of criminal
Behavior order
here's the video of him getting arrested
oh [__] dude
huh let's go come on let's go
this guy is actually
such a threat the police know who he is
oh dude come on you're 18. you got your
whole life ahead of you
got to be better ways
uh video was posted of mizzy trying to
hack a train in London this is the first
one I saw of him that absolutely blew my
[__] mind
s
[Music]
military
oh yeah
[Music]
sick as a prosecutor I love this video
Epic
so freaking Epic
I mean 18 year olds are dumb asses I
guess but God damn
is this what's going on over there in in
the UK
it's going on kids acting like idiots on
the internet and just
they don't have they don't have a
monopoly on that over in the UK the
English are losing it
they're still recovering from the fall
of the empire
let's see he appeared in court on three
separate charges who's accused of
endangering safety Judge Rose Edwin told
mizzy that he has shown blatant
disregard for complying with court
orders mizzy was granted bail and
ordered into custody of his mother
dude these people are so soft I feel
like in America he'd be in jail for like
15 years done like by life was over
but America's [__] up good thing right
that is not a good thing
but at the same time I feel like you're
being a little soft on them too
I don't know I don't know I don't know
what the appropriate punishment I mean
for this like going into people's house
when their kids there stealing someone's
puppy going into the train
operating room and pushing but there's a
hole again like but I don't know I think
he needs a little bit more I mean the
train one I guess like if there was a
possibility he could accidentally like
flip the wrong switch and get that [__]
moving though yeah that'd be pretty
pretty bad he they says he was ordering
the custody of his mother yeah he's 18
who's already living there
go home
it's like time out where you get to go
to your room and play video games
a prior arrest back in February Missy
posted a video in which he sneaks up
behind the ultra Orthodox Jewish man
puts his hands on his shoulder and tries
to jump over him he was then arrested
for racially aggravated assault he said
but after 12 hours of custody was told
he was being charged with criminal
damage but not a hate crime
dude that's great this kid's got a rap
sheet man
there it is Missy
Dan says he's a sweet kid at heart and
uh
I agree he needs a little something he
needs like maybe 30 days
that's what I would do sure
anything is more I wouldn't give him
more than 30 days Dan is jealous of me
at least you know the public would be
safe for those 30 days damn
all the people in that City lives and
can like sleep for 30 days if somebody
in the chat said criminal tomfoolery
charging with that criminal Tom Ford I'm
fine with that I'm not trying to send
him away either
but the kids he needs he needs a little
something we need some like Dr Phil Boot
Camp or something
no aren't those like crazy abuse yeah
yeah they'll they'll molest him there oh
God that'll teach him
I hope you get ass cancer and die you
son of a [__] I'll cut your throat I'll
come to your house and kill you those
places are those places are insane bill
yeah those places are worse than prison
man
but uh
okay free Missy
he's just boys will be boys
no I'm not trying to yeah no the train
one in particular the dog because if
somebody took my dog and ran off I want
them dead
so insane
if somebody walked in my house with my
kids there like that scared my kids dead
bro
yeah it's not good it's not good send
them to the ranch
it's criminal tomfoolery send him to the
ranch
he'll never come he won't come back the
same I'll tell you what
um
spend the evening with the uh drill
sergeant find out what real punishment
looked like
no Ranch coming down oh Bob hey boy why
don't you shine them chrome wheels for
me to sit back here and watch it bend
over like that no Ranch down here on the
ranch I tell you man some people come
spent of change for the better
I ain't never seen nothing like that on
the ranch I'll tell you if these parents
knew what really happened here
last place be empty
but they keep sanding them
we sent them back they just ain't the
same
there's this boy Missy
come around here the ranch teach them a
couple lessons
yeah I taught him a couple of lessons
took them out in the cornfield nearby
like
just me and the boy Rizzy Missy
[Music]
and we just picked corn and then cooked
it and had a good old barbecue
[Applause]
we had we just had a good time and then
he went home and he was healed
and it was a happy ending for everybody
It suffers
um
it was actually super happy uh ending
and he went home he never did a crime
again
went to Cambridge
got a PhD invented a new particle it
discovered the chainsaw yeah in fact uh
he invented anti-gravity technology
we beat gravity we beat gravity whizzy's
in the chat
rezzy's The Man became a prime minister
then he became Pope
Pope too yep Pope what a life what a
journey
so we're very happy with the ranch's
performance it has a proven track record
and I think more kids need to be sent
there we got the music playing
we love him for that
all right listen everybody we had a
fantastic episode how long we've been
going chews let's check in on Malik
before we leave real fast did he finish
he's still going uh well one of them is
totally done the other as he pointed out
the handle is a little [__]
um one in a million oh it's a one in a
million uh yeah I don't know um
I I went and played around with it and
it does seem messed up so I think he
might actually be right about that I
just went pee in the other one and that
is completely functional how's the door
feel good wow feels good solid it felt
good it honestly feels different I'm
gonna it's gonna take some getting used
to to open and close that door but I
think we'll get there I think we'll yeah
we'll overcome we will be peeing and
pooping
in total
nirvana in there
you know uh we gotta have him on when he
finishes the debrief on the project
the door fixing yeah debrief yeah finish
you know
although we should think of some really
crazy [__] up project for him to work
on
yeah well he's local now so I know a
dude with a prolapse who's trying to get
a 3D image
seemed to it seemed into that
somebody said no it's over already or
three it's been three and a half hours
yeah it's a three and a half hour I gave
you all I've got to be fair yeah we got
stuff to do people
AKA Zelda baby wait what are you holding
his third switch
what's happening I returned the other
one I got so I could I'm like if I'm
gonna get a new Switch I might as well
get this Zelda one you got the he got
the official Zelda okay you you returned
the other one so that you could get the
one with the Zelda r on it correct
because I have a bunch of Zelda [__] in
Michigan so I was like I might as well
okay stay on theme the Collector's
Edition real nerd [__] how is everybody
doing in Zelda I think I'm nearing the
end I gotta say the last this is pushing
through I pushed on with the
main quests and I'm not sure how much is
left but I've got I did all the the
temples I got the whole crew with me you
know and uh I'm on the last Temple now
but I feel like I I haven't really done
I feel like I haven't gone at all still
they're still so just running around
doing [__] yeah I did a ton of side
stuff but I was starting to
I was like okay let's let's push on with
the main quest that's where I'm at kind
of I'm ready to go yeah yeah I'm doing
the desert part
that Temple's cool I haven't got to the
temple yet it was maybe my favorite of
the fourth okay that's fun yeah is that
the last one you did too they kind of
set it up where the furthest one
we all did like theoretically you can do
them any order but it definitely I don't
know if the game adapts the difficulty
but the enemies in the last one felt
they're definitely stronger so I I think
there's a preferred order that they kind
of push you towards I think they do
adapt because now when I'm just walking
around the normal area like the Goblins
are stronger higher level maybe it does
maybe the world levels up with you
Diablo players I'm trying to finish so I
can play Diablo
yeah yeah all my buddies started that
this past weekend they were trying to
get me to hop on and play and it was
like I can't start Diablo when I'm still
[__] obsessed with the Zelda again no
one at a time one listen I'm a
monogamous guy right yeah I'm committed
Caleb said I don't have a lot of money
so there's probably last time I can
donate stop dude can we return that
please don't do that then
however I want to put the secrets of
Hillsong documentary on Ethan's radar
with peace and love I better check it
out then
you went into poverty to make Hillsongs
that uh
that Christian Church let some call a
cult
oh what's his name Bieber is involved oh
celebrities go to it right it's like
kind of the story yo okay
that's a hundred percent something I
would want to watch thank you Caleb uh
but please please whole song that's the
the church that's Selena Gomez Justin
Bieber Haley beaver I just learned about
it for the first time yeah this came oh
this just came out last month
how serendipitous
I'm gonna send this to ELA so we can
watch it on the radar thank you Caleb
Caleb yeah it was Caleb thank you Caleb
I'm sorry that
you can't afford lunch you can't afford
to donate
uh don't
that's why I wish I could cancel it I
think YouTube would have to do that do a
chargeback chargeback Caleb please
charge back I don't care that's
YouTube's problem
charge back the [__] out of them
tell them someone stole your car so
that's probably illegal don't do that
yeah maybe don't do any fraud or
anything but don't don't break yeah
don't break the law
but we have a you know operate in the
gray space
all right guys
what a show it's been what a show so
much fun so much laughs oh there's a
Chris Pratt Scandal Olivia you gotta
look into
I haven't even heard about it like a
triple A actor was like being super
homophobic or transphobic I remember
what to someone on the crew and it was
Chris Pratt it's apparently allegedly
Chris Pratt he's there have been rumors
that he has um
conservative beliefs oh he is for sure
yeah but but it's super religious too
isn't he yeah yeah yeah I'll totally
look at it it sounded really interesting
what
I don't I just look Chris Pratt's
Scandal and I don't see anything it's
probably just a tick tock it's probably
just a do do more of us
huge news though now look into it
there's something there thank you lucky
B for the donut or the gifted thank you
everyone who gifted and donated
appreciate you all so very much
uh thank you to all of our members I'm
sorry that there won't be an episode for
members tomorrow but I promise you I'll
be
in a great faith negotiations with my
new best friend
who I will never disparage again
also there was a long BTS we put out
last Friday if you haven't watched that
so that's something about BTS out there
and uh so we'll see you guys on
Wednesday
have a great night
have a great tomorrow
and we'll see oh yeah it was an Elliott
page thing it was with Elliot page
I don't know if he said I think
so people think that that was Chris
Pratt yes so this was in Lafayette and
people are guessing okay yes Elliot page
wrote about how some Triple A actor was
like insanely wow I don't know if it was
homophobic or transphobic because I
don't remember the exact quote but it
was like super [__] up damn and I
guess he was on a show with Chris or
movie with Chris Pratt around that time
yeah I'm looking up to see what right I
read that was like um didn't even say
like I I could [__] you straight or
something yes yeah yes I could [__] you
straight are you kidding that's what
that's what this person said
uh oh yeah yeah
let's look and do it we'll talk about it
I'm not seeing anything allegedly
allegedly allegedly together so
well we'll we'll check it out anyway
guys thank you have a great night we'll
see you on Wednesday God bless stay good
be good
and uh
stay off the murder porn
please
no murder for me don't choose in your
pants
[Music]
thank you